c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur france 24 à la
une ce soir cette nouvelle attaque dans
le nord du bénin un commissariat de
lancer dans une commune située près de
la frontière avec le niger a été ciblé
un policier a été tué il ya plusieurs
blessés nous serons à cotonou dans ce
journal la libération d'alpha condé qui
fait polémique en guinée depuis vendredi
l'ancien président guinéen détenu depuis
le coup d'état du 5 septembre est libre
de ses mouvements mais les victimes de
son régime demande à ce qu'il soit vrai
1 traduit devant la justice la
correspondance à conakry dans un masque
la lutte contre le paludisme au kenya le
pays est à la pointe de la technologie
notamment pour le dépistage nos
correspondants anaérobie sont allés à la
rencontre des scientifiques sur le front
reportage à suivre à la fin de ce jour
le bénin a de nouveau été la cible d'une
attaque terroriste c'est la deuxième
fois en un mois une fois de plus c'est
dans le nord du pays frontalier avec le
burkina faso et le niger que s'est
déroulée la tacc des djihadistes en
cibler un commissariat un policier a été
tué ce qui inquiète c'est le modus
operandi pour la première fois ce sont
des hommes armés en moto qui ont mené l
attaque les précisions de notre
correspondante à cotonou emmanuel sotchi
l'apts terroriste n'est pas encore
confirmée par les autorités béninoises
elles n'ont donné aucune information
mais le mode opératoire il ressemble un
selon des experts en sécurité avec qui
j'ai pu parler c'est un commissariat
situé dans l'extrême nord du bénin qui a
été pris pour cible dans la nuit de
lundi à mardi alors ce qui est inédit
c'est la première fois depuis décembre
des u21 que le mode opératoire a changé
jusqu'à présent lors de tous les
incidents il s'agissait de mines
artisanales ou d'embuscades auxi blesser
ou tuer des militaires au passage de
leur véhicule
et là il s'agit d'une attaque huit
hommes qui seraient arrivés sur quatre
motos devant le commissariat de mende
c'est dans la commune de karimama pas
loin de la frontière avec le niger il ya
eu des échanges de tirs un policier a
été tué ensuite les assaillants ont mis
le feu au commissariat avant de prendre
la fuite en direction du parc de la
pendjari selon les sources locales
les derniers incidents remontent au 10
et au 11 avril dernier il y avait eu au
moins cinq morts du côté des soldats
béninois dans le nord ouest du bénin à
la frontière avec le burkina faso est
depuis la fin d'année dernière et bien
l'extrême nord du bénin est la cible
d'actes terroristes en février trois
attaques à la bombe artisanale dans le
parc de la w à proximité de celui de la
pendjari ont fait neuf morts et 12
blessés parmi les équipes de
surveillance de ses parts qui sont gérés
par african parks l'omg sud africaine à
former ses propres joueurs c'est le
travail au côté des militaires béninois
à traquer les braconniers les
trafiquants et déjà distincts sur une
immense zone qui est couverte de forêts
de savane où les frontières sont très
poreuse alors les groupes qui sévissent
au mali au niger et au burkina faso
cherche à progresser vers la côte en
novembre dernier il y avait une grosse
opération donc de grande envergure entre
le burkina faso la côte d'ivoire le togo
et le ghana dans le cadre de la lutte
contre la progression indique terrorisme
et des groupes criminels organisés et
puis en février dernier le président
patrice talon a demandé une coopération
militaire renforcée avec les voisins sur
la zone frontalière de la pendjari
et puis cet accord entre le fonds
monétaire international et le bénin le
fmi elle devrait accorder un plan daide
de 658 millions de dollars étalés sur
trois ans et demi pour aider le pays
affecté notamment par la guerre en
ukraine ce plan sera toutefois soumis à
l'approbation du conseil
d'administration du fmi la cus qui se
réunira autour de la mi juin
on part à présent en guinée où la
libération d'alpha condé l'ancien
président fait débat dans le pays les
militaires au pouvoir depuis le coup
d'état du 5 septembre ont annoncé qu
alpha condé pouvait recevoir sa famille
et les responsables politiques de son
parti si cette annonce réjouit ses
proches elle n'est pas du tout du goût
des victimes de son régime la
correspondance à conakry le mali diakité
cette annonce continue d'alimenter les
débats au sein de la classe politique
mais aussi de la société civile il ya
ceux qui approuvent la décision de la
junte de libérer alpha condé ce qui la
condamne fermement le rpg le
rassemblement du peuple de guinée sa
formation politique
avait faire de cette libération une
exigence pour prendre part au dialogue
politique sur mon corps est suspendu à
l'effet fractionnement d'avoir des
éléments qui nous précise éventé en tout
cas de manière concrète que cette
libération est faite déciller vous le
savez tant qu'il est là bas nous sommes
pratiquement enchaîné avec l'outil nous
tenons à ce que le cnrd nous rassure
mais avec justement des éléments qui
nous conte concrets qui nous permet de
dire que oui il est libre pour le moment
nous attendons pour les victimes de son
régime cette libération est perçu comme
une manière de permettre à celui qui a
dirigé le pays de 2010 à 2020 en
d'échapper à la justice pendant que
monsieur va contre vérités pouvoir n'a
jamais voulu mettre en place dans le
cours de la justice qui aurait pu
permettre éventuellement de la terre
devant la justice pour les cas de crimes
qu'il a commis pendant qu'il est au
pouvoir désormais nous voulons que
quiconque ou d'un acte point de vue les
pieds sur le projet de loi relatif hélas
cela doit commencer par ici a raconté
depuis la prise du pouvoir par les
militaires plusieurs anciens cadres du
régime déchu sont poursuivis et
condamnés pour des faits présumés de
corruption mais les enquêtes pour les
crimes présumés lors des manifestations
contre le troisième mandat d'alpha condé
sont encore au point mort
on en vient aux funérailles des victimes
morts dans l'explosion d'une raffinerie
légale au sud du nigeria au total cent
personnes sont décédées dans cet
accident le renverse techer revient sur
cet accident qualifié de catastrophe par
le président
l'explosion a tout emporté sur son
passage la plupart des corps été si
gravement brûlé et défiguré que même
leurs familles ne sont pas parvenus à
les identifier
nous avons décidé de les enterrer dans
une fosse commune on ne pouvaient pas
les identifier car ils étaient trop
gravement brûlé est
survenu dans une raffinerie clandestine
ce week end l'explosion a été qualifiée
de désastre national par le président
nigérian qui a appelé à intensifier la
répression de ces exploitations
illégales elles représentent un
véritable fléau dans le sud du nigeria
où des criminels siphonne régulièrement
les pipelines des grandes compagnies
pétrolières pour échapper aux
régulations et aux impôts mais selon les
habitants il faut avant tout s'attaquer
aux causes la pauvreté et le chômage qui
pousse chaque année des millions de
jeunes à se tourner vers des activités
criminelles m le taux de chômage est
trop élevé dans cette science nous
sommes négligé abandonné et sont la vie
est tellement difficile ici on voit que
les femmes les enfants et les jeunes
sont prêts à tout pour suri ming sauvage
au-delà des risques d'explosion les
raffineries clandestine sont une source
majeure de pollution de l'air et
provoque régulièrement des troubles
respiratoires chez les populations
avoisinantes
début avril les autorités nigérianes
avaient annoncé le démantèlement d'une
trentaine d'exploitations similaire en
moins de deux semaines
ces violences au darfour qui ont fait
quatre morts elles ont débuté à acre inc
à 80 kilomètres d'el geneina la capitale
du darfour ouest entre combattants
arabes et non arabes des violences au
lendemain d'une des journées les plus
meurtrières dans cette région de l'ouest
du soudan avec 168 morts et 98 blessés
les précisions de notre correspondant
dans la région bastien nouilles
on commence seulement à comprendre ce
qu'il s'est passé dans le village de
kernic ce week end à l'ouest du darfour
il semblerait que vendredi des
affrontements ont eu lieu entre tribus
africaines et tribus arabes faisant une
dizaine de morts suite à sa l'un des
gouverneurs de la région a décidé
d'envoyer sur place l'armée afin de
calmer la situation l'armée qui s'est
retirée de queyries nick dimanche matin
à l'aube et c'est à ce moment là que des
miliciens djandjawid ont attaqué selon
mes contacts sur place qui m'envoient de
nombreuses vidéos des centaines d'hommes
sur des motos à dos de cheval ou encore
à l'arrière de pick up qui appartenaient
aux forces de soutien rapides cette
milice qui obéit au numéro deux du
régime le général aimetti honte attaquer
les civils assassinés entre 168 et 200
personnes s'attaquant aussi aux enfants
faisant des centaines de blessés suite à
ça les troubles se sont déplacés vers la
ville voisine d'el geneina la capitale
du darfour ouest et cette ville qui est
coutumière du fait et régulièrement il
ya des attaques contre les groupes de
déplacés qui vivent faisant à chaque
fois des dizaines voire des centaines de
morts cette fois ci bien les troubles
ont eu lieu à l'intérieur de l'hôpital
où s'étaient réfugiés les victimes de
guerre inique certaines ont été
assassinés hengelo moins quatre morts de
nombreux blessés et les médecins ont
décidé bien d'arrêter de travailler ils
avaient peur d'être tués à leur tour et
ce mardi il ne semble pas que la
situation se calme dans la lettre du
darfour où les combats et les tensions
continues entre les différentes
communautés
dans las de l'actualité en bref et en
images l'initiative damade néjib chebbi
en tunisie figure politique de gauche et
opposant historique sous la dictature de
zine el abidine ben ali il a annoncé la
création du fonds de salut national
un front 1 regroupant plusieurs partis
politiques pour je cite sauver la
tunisie l'opposant fait allusion à la
grave crise institutionnelle après le
coup de force du président queille cède
4 ans de prison ferme à l'encontre du
militant arabi el hattab blacks au maroc
une condamnation pour je cite offense
envers la personne du roi par voie
électronique l'homme de 35 ans devra
également s'acquitter d'une amende de 20
mille dirhams 1900 euros son avocat va
faire appel
en algérie hakim des basiques militants
pacifiques du shirak mort en prison a
été inhumé ce mardi la ligue algérienne
de défense des droits de l'homme a
appelé à l'ouverture d'une enquête sur
les circonstances de sa mort l'homme de
55 ans fait partie de ces activistes
condamnés par la justice algérienne
à des peines de prison ferme pour leur
publication sur les réseaux sociaux
on vous parle encore ce soir de la lutte
contre le paludisme et on vous emmène
cette fois au kenya le pays est un
exemple dans la lutte contre cette
maladie sur le continent il a accueilli
les essais du vaccin son taux de
prévalence est en constante diminution
passant de 8% en 2015 à 6 % en 2020 un
chiffre qui pourrait être encore plus
bas si la pandémie de covin 19 n'avait
pas ralenti les efforts pour lutter
contre la maladie les autorités ont
depuis décidé de multiplier les efforts
pour endiguer le paludisme notamment à
travers la création du premier test
entièrement fabriqué en afrique nos
correspondants elodie cuisant et bastien
renouil ont rencontré les scientifiques
sur le front
ce test de diagnostic du paludisme vient
tout juste d'être créée par ces
scientifiques kényan il coûte 50
centimes d'euro cinq fois moins que ceux
importés jusqu'à présent le pays a
besoin de 15 millions d'unités par an la
production locale va permettre de
grandes économiques n use the leading le
kenya est un exemple blues c'est le
premier pays à produire un test la palud
il enflamme non seulement en afrique de
l'est la cession du continent tous les
pays les importantes jusqu'à présent et
nous aussi notamment depuis la corée ou
la chine va prendre maintenant nous
allons va fournir tout le continent
africain bridge dans cette pièce les
scientifiques élèves eux-mêmes les
moustiques qui serviront à leur
recherche il étudie le vaccin contre le
paludisme développe des insecticides et
séquences même l'adn du parasite
l'objectif identifier des résistances
aux médicaments
le laboratoire partage ensuite les
résultats avec les autres pays de la
région bienvenue en communication
constante avec les gouvernails honda de
tanzanie les tirs réels nous avons
observé par exemple que l'équipe de
dépistage marge de moins en moins
formant la situation de leur pays et
nous leur disons par exemple qu'elles
soient des médicaments il résistance est
à parler échanger les informations entre
pays du continent c'est l'un des buts de
l'alliance des dirigeants africains
contre le paludisme
les chefs d'état décident ensemble des
politiques publiques pour lutter contre
la maladie nombre d'entre elles ont
d'abord été testé avec succès au kenya a
strong belinda tout irlandais pat je
crois fermement que nous sommes sur la
bonne voie pour mettre le but most
affecté passé nous avons effectué le
grand progrès presque 50 % de diminution
du taux de prévalence des rouges je
pense qu'il ya des régions où nous
allons bientôt quasiment éliminer la
maladie et d'autres où nous aurons
encore du travail pour réduire son
fardeau album back to be able to reduce
de
l'alliance s'est donné pour objectif
d'éradiquer le paludisme avant 2030 un
but difficile à atteindre mais selon les
officiels kenyans leur pays a de fortes
chances d'y parvenir
voilà c'est la fin du journal de
l'afrique rester avec nous dans quelques
instants la suite de paris direct avec
audrey racines
[Musique]